hello everybody I wanted to thank the
organizers for inviting us all here I
think it's better a really productive
and fun workshop I want to tell you well
I guess I'd show you who i am i'm jeff
clown I'm from the University of Wyoming
and I there had the evolving artificial
intelligence laboratory shows you a hint
of why I'm interested in evolution
because I wanted to really or you or
Jaguars hawks and human brain and I'm
going to tell you arguably some bad news
but I think it's at least interesting
for the discussion that we've been
having here and these are two projects
where I set out to try to get evolution
to do to evolve vulnerability I wanted
evolution to speed itself up and do
something that would help produce
complexity and in both cases I failed to
get evolution to evolve evolve ability
and in both cases I found another way
that we can get it to do it but it's for
non-adaptive reasons so these are two
papers that I've put together one is on
the evolution mutation rates and the
other ones on the evolution of
modularity and usually there's
completely separate topics but at this
conference I thought it was interesting
that both of them had this property
together so I'll quickly tell you about
them separately and then I'll try to
wrap up wise and just some unifying
themes so the first paper is from plos
computational biology this is work that
I did with Richard Lensky Charles of
Frida and some really clever Spanish
scientists and the conclusions are all
in the title and that is the natural
selection fails to optimize mutation
rates for long-term adaptation on rugged
fitness landscapes so it's a lot of
caveats in there all those are necessary
and I'll tell you generally the story
but the the highest level summary of it
is that natural selection as we all know
is very short-sighted and a loan on low
mutation rate is very very good in the
long term but is very bad in the short
term in terms of average fitness and so
evolution will always take the myopic
route and be short-sighted and lower its
mutation rate as long as it's on a
rugged fitness landscape so let me show
you the evidence that i have for that
first to motivate it mutation rates we
know are a key driver of vulnerability
we've talked about that a lot here and
that raises a question whether or not
they are optimized for long-term
adaptation and I hope to convince you
that they're not so how do you do that
experimentally the general idea is no
matter what the system is the best thing
experiment i could do is i can take a
group of organisms such as
and I fix the mutation rate I don't let
it change over time I let it evolve for
a long period of time and I record the
final fitness however I do that so I'll
plot that so this mutation rate gave me
this fitness and then i'll take another
group of yeast and i'll raise that
mutation rate a little bit and then fix
it lock it in let it evolve for a while
and evolve their final fitness and plot
that and as you can expect if you do
that it's probably going to be some
intermediate mutation rate that is
optimal for long-term adaptation okay
then the question is what evolution find
it so how do I do that well I'll take a
group of organisms that are up here at a
high mutation rate and I'll have up your
goes to start with a low mutation rate
and now let the mutation rate evolve and
then I'll find do they converge on this
optimum fitness rate or do they go
somewhere else now Daniel give a straw
poll of all of us a while back and a
very few people said they thought
evolution would go down here many which
implies either the people don't have an
answer yet or that they think that
evolution would go here so we'll see
what happens in our experiments so the
system that we use to study this is a
veena which some of you have heard about
before it's a computational evolution
system and you know if you don't want to
get into the details of it all you
really need to know is that it's a
system that's been well that it a lot of
biologists have learned a lot from it
and have cared what came out of it and
it's a population of self-replicating
digital organisms on a very complicated
fitness landscape so I could spend hours
telling you about the system and trying
to convince you that it's interesting
but I don't have time for that today so
just take my word for it if you will
that is a complicated fitness landscape
of self-replicating organisms I will
tell you a little bit about it just so
you have a picture it's the each
organism is a string kind of like a
turning tape of computational
instructions they push numbers around
they pop numbers they actually have to
copy their own genome that's the
self-replication part and then we asked
that we ask them to do two different
things we asked them to the faster they
replicate the more offspring they have
because there's limited space in the
environment and then they also have to
get better at solving some tasks some
hard tasks and what you see this is a
bird's eye view of this here Fitness is
on the whoops listen on Fitness is on
the y-axis and basically fitness rises
over time
so you can see these kind of a selective
sweeps so somewhere in here a mutation
will happen it will raise fitness and
you see it spread out of the population
and then on that backdrop of clonal
interference you'll also have other
mutations come along in those genetic
backgrounds and slowly over time fitness
raises and we've done a lot of work over
decades in this system now and we can
tell you that it's a very complicated
fitness landscape to navigate so this is
this is actually just space so you're
it's a spatial structured population so
you get born near your neighbors and
then fitness is on the other axis so we
don't give it one specific task in some
sense it's kind of more just that faster
application happens but if you do tasks
you speed up okay so I know that that's
a very very light introduction of the
model because i don't think the details
of the model to relevant except that
it's a complicated fitness landscape so
what happened so if i fix the mutation
right to here on this log scale and then
I run evolution out for a period of time
that we get to a certain fitness so with
that mutation rate my final fitness is
up here and then I go and I set my
mutation rate to be this amount here and
the overall population ends up here and
I take the final Fitness is here of
these we take fixed mutation rates and I
plot them and we get this curve here
which means there is an intermediate
optimal mutation rate in this system and
it's that if you go too high then you're
above a you start going back down and
fitness and too low and you don't go
very far so then what do we do we take a
group of organisms that start here above
the with a higher mutation rate that is
optimal another group that starts with
the really low mutation area actually
they started here and then I let them
evolve and what does evolution do with
Don mutation right well what it does is
it floors it passes right through the
optimal zone and set to the orders of
magnitude below what is optimal for
long-term adaptation and you can see the
result in Fitness here so had they done
the optimal mutation rate they would
have ended up here in fitness space they
end up down here in fitness on this log
plot here so I can show you that over
time here we go I'm going to if I fix
the mutation rate of the optimal this is
what fitness looks like over time
if I start high I do get some adaptation
because i had a while i'm trying to
lower my mutation rate while evolutions
trying to learn me t-shirt as fast as
possible I happen to get some adaptation
but once evolution accomplishes its goal
of decreasing the mutation rate then
this is what happens to my adaptation
over time I shut it off that's what
evolution is wanting to do in this
system now interestingly if I start with
a very low mutation rate it actually
does go up a little bit because I'm on
the side of a fitness speak and there's
some low-hanging fruit around there so I
get some hitchhiking and then it starts
to go back down once I find a big enough
peak that I'm surrounded by valleys it's
my hypothesis so and this is the fitness
over time I do get some adaptation that
I showed it off again so spoiler alert
if anybody here raises the fact that
mutate mutator alleles show up in
experimental evolution populations such
as riches richland cheese experiments he
and I think that this is what's going on
there you do get this raising but it's
still very very very much lower than the
optimal long-term mutation rate yeah you
can do that I've tried that and it
doesn't make a difference basically I'll
show you the side of the end we tried
everything you can think of and there's
nothing you can do to get rid of this a
result well there's one thing I don't
tell you what that is so why this has
happened well I think most of the people
in this room probably have a pretty good
intuition and that is because if I'm on
a peek this is our hypothesis then the
average fitness of organism has a very
low mutation rate is the average of all
the organisms it didn't move very far
they're all in the peak that is a higher
average fitness than this organism which
is putting many of its offspring down in
the valley now obviously if I can jump
the valley if why I can put a thing over
here then we'll run up but then we'll
just repeat the problem over here and so
eventually what happens is that why
outcompetes ever sorry exhale competes
why that's the supposition now that was
our hypothesis so how can we test that
hypothesis well if it's the ruggedness
of the fitness valley that matters then
I can test that by making a smooth
fitness landscape so I'm going to take
this complicated of vidya in landscape
which I can't even map because too high
dimensional and too complex but I know
has a lot of valleys or at least I
assume and I'm going to just make it
basically put these organisms on the
side of an infinite slope and that slope
has no valleys in it so this is your
simple counting one problems where you
just want to have more and more and more
ones and then I can change the
environment and go the other way and
make them always on the side of a slope
now this one has no valleys I can also
add a valley by just saying okay an
intermediate amount of these ones in
this genome is bad right with me so
what's going to happen this is the
answer when I'm on a smooth fitness
landscape there are no fitness valleys
this is the optimal the sweet stuff that
you just make the wireless cat fair
point it's hard to do yeah I don't
happen what's the smaller size so this
is the this is the optimal mutation
right here and evolution started high or
low perfectly finds it so on a smooth
fitness landscape evolution will
optimize its mutation rate for long term
adaptation and in one little Valley
evolution comes right over it doesn't
even see it still optimizes it but as
the valley size grows wider and wider
here and then here then the resulting
the result of evolution gets further and
further away from the optimum and the
final fitness becomes orders of
magnitude lower in the afternoon oh so
does from it yeah this demands you
Juliana populations are you sure am I
supposition is we debated at lunch is
that if I increase the population size I
would increase the size of the valley at
which it happens but it will eventually
happen I just have to go down a few bars
you view rows of my club yes right yeah
obviously the kind of questions like the
scaling what's the skin between those
sure and you're all of your work you did
yesterday is extremely related to it if
I can cross it in a short enough time
that I can cross it be for the selective
sweep on the lower the advantageous
lower mutation rate fixes then I'm good
and if I fix before that happens that
I'm not good but i want to point
something out because everybody thinks
that oh it's just a matter of crossing
time and if as long as the valley is
narrow enough and i can kind of
consistently cross that i'll be good but
i want to point out something
even more insidious about this that
makes the effect much much stronger and
that is it a self-reinforcing process so
let's assume I'm walking along this
fitness landscape I come to this valley
and in the first generation if I cross
I'm good in the second generate the
first generation all of my offspring are
down in here then there is now selective
pressure for me to lower my mutation
rate now the lower mutation rate
actually makes it even less likely that
i'm going to cross the valley because
i've narrowed the banda mutations that
i'm generating so the whole time that
i'm waiting for that lucky event across
the valley i'm actually exponentially or
whatever that depends on the amex of the
system but i am decreasing rapidly the
chance that i will then make the
crossing so if you ever find yourself in
a natural fitness landscape even if
you're not on a perfect feet but if you
want a functional peak meaning that it's
rare form that generates and beneficial
mutations then you're going to start
ratcheting down you eat anything and
even less likely you find those rare
alleles and the process quickly will
drop your mutation rapidly yeah usually
met these nobodies long right so you can
I mean you have to end this environment
actually switching between these all the
time but you still you're running and
then you have to make this jump so
basically the question is do you ever
run into a situation where a very small
fraction of you mutations are beneficial
and if so in that environment you're
going to start lowering your mutation
right so if you're always always always
in a case where a huge fraction mutation
rates are beneficial if you can
construct that Andres for me we're good
if not we've got a problem so I mean I
think the idea is that ok you would
start you know you start lowering your
mutation rate but if the system is big
enough there's some weirdo somewhere who
didn't get it realized that he was
supposed to be lowered as mutation and
right and one of those will be the one
that actually crosses that and then
they'll come sweep in and kick you out
that's right and as long and in all of
our experiments here that's exactly what
happens most of the population is
dropping its rate won't happen to leave
it high and cross the valley and that's
fine but if you keep doing this for a
long enough period of time eventually
that person doesn't get lucky enough
soon enough then the population is
dropping mutation rate and then we're
kind of in this lower space it becomes
harder and harder to do that so it you
know
that will that game will work a few
times so all I have to do is the
lowering advocate is it will once and
then the game is over you have to win
every time we play play time is somebody
in the world has to win that's right
those are the only ones who see if I was
happy I was just the lowering direct
arrow and he knows the aisle cordero so
he gets everyone in the population but
one of his players has to win every time
if ever I win then it's none of the game
is over because you could revolve a high
mutation rate but you kind of see the
net effect of this there's a whole lot
of arrows pointing down a mutation rate
and it's you know harder and harder to
construct arrows I think that pop it up
this is what we're crucially depends
upon number all kinds of bunkers yeah
that's right and so if we have an
absolute infinite population size than
this repair this never happens yeah I
agree with you so I think about this at
least does is it kind of fuels our
intuition that it's probably a harder to
construct situations which evolution
will optimize its long-term mutation
rate that we originally thought before
you did this work I'm not saying you
can't construct those those situations
so here's the slide where the reviewers
basically did what all of you guys are
doing which is what did you try this if
you tried this one but there's this
might be something that you think that
would work and I actually know the
reviewers Chris Adami and I've never had
her you were coming through more rounds
of requested experiments there was like
seven of them but we had to change the
size of each acre make changes the
frequency of changes we had to make
increases far more likely than decreases
because obviously in nature it's easy
it's harder to evolve proofreading than
to get rid of it so you make this hugely
asymmetric doesn't make a difference and
we also critically critically we also
made them self-reflexive which actually
makes it harder to to decrease your rate
with so whether the mutation rate
applies to itself and why that's harder
I can tell you the coffee break it's
kind of an interesting phenomenon but
it's not relevant yeah it has a name
from from it's called ortho Kinesis
trying to understand why bacteria would
set up gradients to a
of food it's just basically they are
randomly diffusing but the better the
food is the slower they go and that
creates a concentration around the high
food rate so that's from the 1950s okay
I'm not familiar with that that sounds
pretty cool um okay we also made them
static versus changing for chrysanthus
comment the rate of change the
complexity of the environment all these
different things different starting
points basically it's very very hard in
fact I challenge any of you code up a
situation which evolution optimize its
me featuring for long-term adaptation
and i will give you this half drunk I
don't have a million-dollar prize yes ah
in whoa um the complexity of these
passes are solving logic tasks so there
are simple logic test or they're nested
higher at the logic did you study moses
james be so we took the original aveda
can complex fitness landscape which
typically you well from ninth ask your
reward nine possible tasks and instead I
involve a reward I could reward 77
that's how I increase the complexity of
the possible of problems they could
solve but to do a changing I randomly
pick a subset of that 77 reward that for
a while and then I stop rewarding those
a reward a different subset and I can
either make them jumping from different
blocks or I can make them slowly over
evolving or one test stops being
rewarded and I swapped it in for new
ones there's always some thing that's
being rewarded across basically do
whatever you want it's not going to work
I know you want it to work I wanted it
to work I even tried I haven't published
if I even tried group selection lineage
selection so I thought that would be the
answer the downward pressure is so
strong here that whatever in word upward
pressure you can get from the edge
selection just doesn't counteract this
is a very very pernicious insidious
strong downward pressure and I'd love to
fight it but I haven't figured out a way
it is the hell true that the DA me ask
for all these is you ask you to make the
grid like I'm figure we did that too oh
you do dash but no I think I think I me
had already done that they were asked
you to do the extrapolation and estimate
record numbers would be in some in the
Sun regime or now that's Daniels job
okay
try a real combination we did in fact
part of this work stems from the fact
that we also want to figure out my
colleague do they miss havoc in the same
lab with Lensky is trying to figure out
when set to the ball that's another one
that's very very dull you try to go
evolution the ability to turn on sex
versus turn it off there you can find
narrow ranges in which it works for
their pretty specialized okay I want to
get on to the other thing but I like
that everybody is kind of agitated
because I've agitated me too so this is
a conclusion I'll just restate the title
because they now you'll understand all
these words natural selection fails
optimize mutation rates for long-term
adaptation on rugged fitness landscapes
in other words natural selection is
short-sighted and I think that sounds
obvious but obviously people here even
disagree with me so I'd like to do
Daniel straw poll again at the end maybe
after that I tell you this other result
that I have so the other result i want
to tell you about which i also think is
pretty exciting is this paper we just
had out in proceedings of the royal
society called the evolutionary origins
of modularity it took HOD Lipson and
jean-baptiste claro and the general just
here as most of you know is that
modularity is the encapsulation of
function into units so in a car for
example you have a bunch of separate
parts in your brain you have a different
scales organization you have different
neural modules and people basically this
is a huge driver of evolvability for the
same reasons it is used in engineering
which is that you can recombine
different building blocks to produce
vastly different phenotypes using
information you've already discovered
and you can also tinker with one within
a module without having cascading
epistatic effects throughout the rest of
the phenotype so it's usually a better
system to design them so for decades now
there's been a quest in the field of
evolutionary algorithms to try to get
evolution to start producing modular
genomes we won't ordered modular genomes
modular neural Nets modular or
phenotypes we want it to use modulate
because we think that's important and if
you could figure that out then it's off
to the races but what's weird is that we
can't get it to work so almost every
time that we try to evolve a genome
network or neural network even if we
give it an extremely modular problem for
you owe everything we
think of basically we almost always gets
entangled spaghetti code everything gets
worried everything evolution does not
produce sub modules and then rewire them
just doesn't happen in our simulations
so that that's a question why did it
happen run it happen in nature why
doesn't it happen in our simulation so
along come cash in cash in allen in 2005
and they produce a hugely impactful
paper which says that if you vary
environments in just the right way on
just the right problems then you will
get the evolution of modularity because
that's a good idea and then that speeds
up evolution the problem with that is
that they had to work really hard for it
and if you implement the results that
you find that it's actually a pretty
narrow perimeter range in which that
result happens if you vary it in almost
any way you can think of and it stops
working so it was a really cool first
result but it's not they're probably not
the general force that got evolution to
modular you to begin with so we wanted
to test a different hypothesis which is
that maybe it's not that modularity
evolves because it's a good idea for
adaptation maybe involves for some other
reason maybe because there are
connection costs in network networks and
this is actually a theory that was
advocated by a founding hopes up for the
next no it's not there oh yeah here we
go founded by a soup there was a
hypothesis made in 1899 by monique aha
the famous neuroscientist and he
couldn't test it because you didn't have
evolutionary algorithms or even
computers there are a lot of costs and
biological networks you actually just
mentioned one that I love in genetic
regulatory networks for their more clear
in brains you have the cost to build a
connection maintain it etc and so
there's also evidence that selection
acts to minimize the connection cost in
a network so if you look at something
like C elegans for example the placement
of neurons actually is optimal to reduce
the wiring cost of the neural network
that it has in its body and so the
reason I wanted to test this hypothesis
is one because we really want it in the
field of evolutionary computation we
want to evolve complexity but also
because we want to enter this biologic
question of waters may modulate is
ubiquitous and biological networks but
we don't see it in our own system so why
did it evolve in nature so what we're
going to do is going to take the problem
from cash in and Allen's paper this is a
eight pixel retina problem so we have a
little tiny retina we show it
whole bunch of patterns I'm going to ask
it questions and you tell me yes or no
if you're going to answer this right or
wrong and the question is is there an
object on the left side and on the right
side so these are the patterns that
count as a left object these are the
patterns that count as the right object
half of that you know there's some
patterns I'm not showing you here that
don't count so I show you eight pixels
and you tell me if there was a pattern
on the left on the right was there this
and this okay now there's two ways you
can solve this problem one is that you
just have one monolithic function that
solves the problem and the other one is
you first fight your ads is a left and a
right and then you bring these things
together okay and they're both there
there's they're both perfectly
performing you can solve the problem
perfectly either way so here is the
entire paper in one slide if you take
this problem and you select just for
evolutionary performance just what we've
been doing in our field for 40 years for
the most part selecting for performance
you get an entangled network that
perfectly solves the problem if you
select instead for performance and you
penalize a connection cost so you make
it expensive you all get to pay for your
connections then you get extremely
modular networks then decompose both
parts of the problem now what's really
interesting is that if you then take
these networks and you put them in a new
environment these networks are much more
evolved they evolve much faster so we
did get evolvability from modularity but
the modularity did not evolve because of
its availability yep so I'm sort of
putting I believe you have a ship's
trouble computationally understanding
what
identifying Morton's yep so let me tell
you how all I'm saying that may be one
reason is because you're where you're
finding motors computationally I'm not
clear what the fuses are or if it is
necessary to how many but yeah that's I
I think it's going to be a complete
occasional Eric after dog screaming for
many reason about the Phoenicians
actually find dachshund find modules
inside your strands okay so I think the
gist of your question is how do you know
that there aren't functional modules in
these networks that you can't see
because they're not they don't pop out
to your eye so we tried to figure that
answer that question in two ways the
first one is that we use an algorithm
that I did an event that can find
modules in networks and we had it split
the network into to the best split into
two modules and then we saw the percent
of time that the inputs relevant to the
left side of the problem are in a
different module and the inputs relevant
to the right side problem and we color
those arbitrarily orange and blue that
the two modules that the algorithm
splits it to what we find is that in
most of the cases fifty-six percent of
the cases in this fraud in the treatment
with a connection cost you get that left
right decomposition of the problem and
you get it in for yet very I think you'd
never get it and in this treatment where
you don't have a connection comes so
that's one way of pro if they are
separating the problem into the left and
right modules and so it never happens
here have been significantly often or
often hear the other ways we tested it
is arguably maybe even a better way
which is that I can look at any neuron
in the network that neuron or this
neuron and I can just see does it I'll
answer the left sub problem perfectly
accurately and is there another neuron
that answers the right sub problem
perfectly accurately so I can tell if
it's solving the two sub problems that
are in this overall problem and that
significantly happens more often in
these networks of these hours I don't
have a step
it is in the paper so I think there's a
two reasons to believe that we honestly
do have different functional
decomposition in two separate modules in
these networks that we do not have in
these networks now let me show you a
little bit more data also this is
modularity over time so it raises in the
connection cause treatment it does not
rise at all this is what we've been one
for 40 years we've been trying to start
problems to see the module area would
rise and we've been seeing this flat
line if you add a connection cost you
suddenly see this huge improvement in
modularity also interesting is that
performance is actually better in them
in the treatment with a connection cost
and this also drove the reviewers mad
because they said well performance is
better in the modular treatment then why
is it evolution doing on its own why do
you need this connection cost and the
answer is because it's better over the
long term it's not always immediately
better on the little coupe that you're
sitting up I think syd the performance
level ones evolved to sell the ground
perfectly so you can get perfect
solutions mystically you get the much
less Auburn river in fact in this data
here which is when I evolved them in one
environment and switched to the other I
control for that by doing so many of
these runs that i eventually get 50
perfect solutions so I have 50 perfect
that both then up in the new environment
and these still a ball faster to avoid
the concerning effective starting off
less ok so you want asked why if you
know if these perform better then why it
doesn't selection of all them and so we
invented a new algorithm try to map out
the space of phenotypes here so I can
show you cost versus modularity and
color is fitness and I created an
algorithm that would actually search
through all different for networks that
have this combination of cost in my
divinity this combination cost and
modularity and then I want the best one
in each point so I can show you kind of
the phenotypic fitness landscape if you
will what you can see is that there are
perfectly performing networks throughout
this space so to some extent this is
also another reason why evolution
doesn't have
to hear to a modular solution to solve
the problem and you can actually see
over time that basically if I want to
keep my connection cost low and keep
fitness high we can stay in the yellow
and eventually I have to ride up this
curve and I end up here so almost all of
the connection costs treatment networks
end up here a modular solutions which
then are primed to evolve better in
future environments where as the
performance alone networks tend to stay
down here they don't get pushed into
that space so I've told you about the
evolvability experiments they have all
faster and then this is to compare the
result of cashton and Alan which is the
frequency of environmental change which
me the cash in an allen result is this
blue line here which means that if
you're in the right range of
environmental change change on the right
problem and you'll get this their
modularity but as long as once you kind
of get out of the right range and the
modularity falls off whereas this
connection cuz kind of produces modular
networks irrespective of the rate of
environmental change so it's a pretty
general result we tried it on different
problems you can see here through some
problems and you can see in every
situation we've tried it on and my labs
and work on this sense pretty much
everywhere we try this it works at a
connection cost and you'll get modular
networks I mean the final thing I want
to point out which I was telling you
about earlier today is that it also
helps with learning so these networks
here we're just evolving networks like a
gene regulatory networks there's no
heavy and learning or anything going on
if I if I actually evolve neural
networks which are brains that are gonna
solve a problem and I give them a
learning algorithm one open question in
science is how does a brain like
yourself learn one task and then when it
switches to a new task why doesn't it
cannibalize that original knowledge
there's no like remaining selection or
on that original problem so natural
animals if you train them on one task
train them on a second task they don't
lose all of their ability to perform the
original task but all of the neural nets
and neural network learning algorithms
that we know about if I train them on
task a it's going to rewire the network
to solve task a really well that if I
change to another tab
that learning algorithm is immediately
going to start changing the weights that
income the information that performed
well on task a tu t'es l tasbeeh now i'm
good on task B I've solved that problem
and now you put a mascot back on task a
and I have to relearn it from scratch I
don't it's not like I've learned both
things in the network the only way to
have a network learn both things is to
train them simultaneously so how do we
solve that problem we can't solve that
problem and we can of all artificial
intelligence that does anything
interesting because it will always be a
one-trick pony so this critical thing
turns out you can actually solve if you
have a modular network why because when
I'm learning task a then I can have a
can consolidate all of my learning in
module a have a module for that task
when i switch a task B turn off learning
in that module turn on in this other
module and learn everything in that task
and now when i switch back to this task
i like to do is just use the other
module is just been sitting there the
whole time so the interaction between
modularity and learning is actually
extremely beneficial to being able to
learn many different tasks without
forgetting them when you learn new tasks
so the biological implications of this
workout I think it may be a major
explanatory explanation for why
biological networks are very modular
check my protein protein networks
genetic regulatory networks neural
networks pretty much anything in biology
but I also think this is interesting for
the evolvability people which is that
this connection cause made bootstrap
evolvability explanations because if you
think that modularity does give you a
vulnerability and that evolution might
select for it I still can't select for
modularity until it starts giving me
that payoff so find an entire space and
over here and this dimension of
modularity here's we're going to start
to get my evolvability payoff but I
start here there's no gradient to evolve
mobility until I get all the way the
modular networks maybe the connection
cost is what produces the modular
networks to begin with and then that can
kind of hand it off to selection for
evolvability which can run off to the
races with it so it also this this helps
us for evolving artificial intelligence
so this is my last slide basically which
is that on two different problems we saw
both mutation rates and of modularity
there is the option
they're for evolution to find a solution
or a technique which would improve its
long-term adaptability and it didn't and
then i added a natural constraint from
nature either a cost for fidelity for
the saying you can't have zero mutation
rates you have to pay for that or i
added costs for connections and all of a
sudden my flip evolution into a state
where it's much more evolvable and it's
much more adaptable so it's it's a
vulnerability in nature but not because
it evolved to be a vulnerable and I'm
not saying that that's always the case
it just makes me wonder how many other
cases of a vulnerability that we see in
nature a rose for non-adaptive reasons
where we're searching for the adaptive
explanation but there's not adaptive one
or the converse which I'd love to hear
this audience discuss in the discussion
how many examples of evolvability for
major do we actually have good reason to
believe our adaptive so I'd love to hear
those examples so with that I'll just
say thank you yeah so effectively what
you're saying is if you made it very
very likely you can go from a low
mutation right back to a height H
yeah we did that and the mutation rate
still went down
what we what we do is we have a number
on the genome which is just annotation
right and evolution can change that so
there's mutations to that number and
then selection does the rest and I think
to implement what I thought I think
you're suggesting is that what I want is
that if I if I do lower over a period of
time once I get low there should be the
chance to jump up pretty fast a big jump
and maybe even more frequent jumps high
than low i implement both of those it
still goes down it'll still sit on me
does that implement what you're
suggesting cash i dinnae i didn't
understand yep eukaryotes they have an
extraordinarily low for base mutation
rate but actually they have a lot of DNA
and so the effective mutation rate is
much higher simply because they put so
much DNA get one which new planet side
skirts spontaneously arise so but we
know that the forces that increase the
length of DNA are very often
non-adaptive in one evolution that tends
to be upward pressure like a symmetric
crossover own transpose are not suppose
on occasions and stuff or not so there
could be a very virtuous situation
whereby the mechanism you describe the
pervasive mutation an extremely low but
there are other mechanisms which force
the general told Jen to get Martha and
sort of keep the effective mutation
yeah but also if a lot of that extra DNA
is junk DNA and those mutations rate
don't really matter I'm inside yeah yeah
yeah that is an interesting thing to
think about I don't know if it's exactly
lady but I think that somebody pointed
this out a couple days ago if you evolve
genetic regulatory networks or genetic
programming networks then effectively
they blow their gene I'll often make the
jhino extremely large so the effective
mutation rate is lower because the
percent of functional stuff in there it
gets much lower just just a fact
throughout it's a legal genetic
programming what the same agility
program that's what I said just now yeah
GP is like fluid is a huge problem in
that it happens all the time yeah other
in the indicates with the two pattern
recognized so are all the if I find a if
I pick a random a good solution with few
edges it's very likely to be modular yes
yeah that's true so I would think that I
kind of connected to the Alliance idea
is that if you started from really
nothing a huge number of instances we
start with nothing and then you start
randomly adding edges then it would
really you're the ones that that manage
to find solutions would be much more
likely to be modular yeah that's true
and you can do that in our networks you
can start with no networks you can let
them be added over time so it has to
pass through this range of sparsity
where maybe it will discover the
solution but again it has to discover in
the short term if you need to stay in
that range in the long term there's some
local Optima where evolution loves to
make everything entangled because it
kind of like is just hacking the best
solution so far it quickly overshoots
thus far strange puts itself into the
highly overly complicated range and then
it's hosed in the long term so this is
why Richard earlier was mentioning my
work in connection with his work this
natural cost for connections might be
one reason that keeps the complexity of
natural models and Metro solutions
low which keeps them the evolvable range
if there was no cost and they would
effectively had a lot of connections and
over fit and we wouldn't get
evolvability in generalization and so I
think that you it's very clear to show
in our dinner situations that that
property starting simply going more
complex won't sell the problem because
they won't hang out in the good range
long enough they'll just overshoot kind
of like the mutation it's almost exact
same invitation rings you can start high
sweep through the good space you're not
going to stay there and you overshoot to
the low space so you're quickly do
regularization then on the networks yeah
that's right and that's a but swear
Richards work and can making the
connection to the biological language
and machine learning language comes into
play yes a connection cost in nature
might enforce regularization not because
it's a good idea because it's just it
happens to be the cost of physical
connections and that helps us evolve and
create better solutions in the same way
that it helps the machine line and then
have you seen people's dropout algorithm
I have so I mean that achieves the same
kind of things that you do except
instead of cost it's just noisy
components basically that's writes to me
much more biologically plausible that's
right and so for those of you in the
audience who don't know what that is
hinton has these giant deep belief in
neural networks and what he does is they
were over fitting and they weren't doing
extremely well in problems so he added
noise to the neurons so half the time
they don't work the inner of the hidden
neurons and all of a sudden performance
generalization went through the roof
everything starts performing better so
yet another example or something from
nature like the happenstance fact the
things sometimes don't work evolution
probably didn't increase that error rate
happens to produce more generalization
and more pay off so maybe there's a
third example of evolvability or
generalization based on an accident of
nature
sorry Daniel argument and a wise men are
Daniel fishing yeah so if you had an
infinite population then and you looked
in retrospect that which one's work then
I think that they would have a lot of
these properties they probably were ones
that if you saw already if you saw them
that's the thing that's why I say with
an infant population if you never got
rid of the bad decisions that we're not
currently performing well and eventually
you might see these properties but
evolution has limited population sizes
and it gets rid of the stuff that's not
working and a lot of times it's getting
rid of stuff that ultimately would help
it where is the question of large yeah
so at lunch that was his answer if you
know give me ten to the twentieth
organisms and I'll solve this problem
and you may be right that may be
something that happened that definitely
factors in its own doesn't help us we're
trying to evolve a I the bigger point
the vibro the picture which I IRC why
keep breathing
just buy products or something else but
you know maybe there's enough byproducts
of something else actually generate
these things for media you need to
evolve in almost any every example you
can you find that okay just because it's
kind of defaulting the probability is
kind of like a second order thing
exactly like you were saying maybe
longer yard sales and every time there's
going to be like a first-order effect
okay as any affection of that system to
the overwhelm that second order term so
it's just ready to get so sometimes it
seems like it because there was a
personal
right but yet given if there is no such
special for connectivity if you look in
retrospect might look as if there is
just selected by because because see
solutions and the one to see they have
to have described they have added into T
noise to the changing of galleries
degree and in all these things we
actually like first order things could
be just you know air raids
yeah I just think the selection pressure
is for the short-term effect of that
second order effect valid variable and
the short-term effect tends to be to
disrupt information which is exactly we
want a long term in the short term that
lowers my average fitness and so I get
rid of it so there is selection on
second order stuff is just selection not
for long term evolvability yeah both
but we tried that that's not going to
work it is the case that have I ran the
entire experiment stopped looked at what
was the better of mutation rate and did
that and then did that again over and
over again so I was always looking at
the long-term effect and selecting on
that then I can select for a good
parameter the problem is that evolution
in the rear old has to operate online
unless it can do that and that's
actually what Richard watching its work
a lot is is when can I kind of
encapsulate it off and try to look at
the long-term time scales and not allow
the short-term effects to sneak in and
disrupt what I want to do in the long
term and if we can figure out mechanisms
by which that happens in nature then
we've discovered the evolution on well
ability
with what happens in nature
there is a common tacit assumption that
combination of all from and a sexual
role yeah and then all these questions
come up the time scale how should we
explain it to a higher buyer for a
theory possibly result but it's also
possible
see the world that has genetic exchange
or exchange of
too far back is there is something we
call
somehow this former life
which changes the nature of the question
does it though because don't you have to
explain its maintenance
in other words it's good question and
since part of the framework implied and
not something that people completely
different world in which case we solve
those questions of by
different view and as far as the
feminist is concerned so we are
our
on that particular point I think that's
absolutely right it makes a lot more
sense to think apparently the evolution
of chromosomes from an ancestral state
those replications that were not me so
chromosomes and molitor's we come back
to you later recommends to run neck pain
first
thank you